why don't we go next to
oh I don't know maybe uh George from
Virginia George welcome to the program
what is on your mind today
hey David uh can you hear me yes I can
awesome
um I'm still traumatized from my last uh
microphone malfunction yeah I'm hoping
that today we can sort of like clear the
air on it
okay uh so I was wondering if you've
seen like
how there's been an influx of like
people attacking the idea of remote work
yes I have seen that
um so there was recently article
published in the New York Times
by Stephen Ratner
and it's called is working from home
really working and like
this guy tries to blame sbv uh collapse
and meta's failures on remote workers
and I can't help but feel like
I'm being attacked because I'm a remote
worker and like
I don't know what their motives are but
it's very disappointing so I saw the
article
um I read a lot in the last couple of
months Pro and against remote work
I actually think that we don't have
nearly enough information yet to say for
sure what are the long-term impacts of
more set in stone remote work we are
very early in you know we had the
pandemic and a ton of stuff went fully
remote and then right now we're still in
a sort of experimental phase where you
know a lot of my friends who are lawyers
at corporate firms they have to be in
Tuesday Wednesday Thursday but Monday
Friday they work from home or other
people it's we have a rotating shift so
like part of the workforce is Monday
Tuesday Wednesday part is Tuesday
Wednesday Thursday parties Wednesday
Thursday you get the idea I don't think
we actually have enough information yet
to say a hundred percent what are all of
the impacts of work from home there have
been studies about so-called
productivity
and what's often repeated is
productivity is no lower when people are
working from home because even if
they're distracted during the day
because home and work are at the same
place they end up kind of just like
doing work at more times or whatever the
case may be for me it's like it's less
about that my view is just a little bit
different my view on this is
it can be better or worse for different
people and companies depending on what
the priorities are right even when you
talk about productivity I don't know how
many people in my audience listen to Cal
newport's podcast it is phenomenal one
of the few podcasts that I actually make
a point to listen to
he has a number of recent episodes about
this sort of thing and in one of them he
talks about you know when we talk about
being productive for some people
productivity means squeezing a ton of
different things into a limited amount
of time and so you got to get organized
for that for others productivity means
actually I want more free time so for me
being productive means squeezing the
things I'm expected to do into fewer
hours to then free me up to do other
things or whatever the case may be a lot
of this George is based on perspective
what do we mean it's good or bad to work
from home is it good or bad productivity
wise mental health socially
environmentally and I just think a lot
of people are expressing opinions about
this right now and the jury is still
sort of out on it
yeah I I agree with that David and I
want to say you know I am a coder so I'm
I am an introvert so it does benefit me
to work from home and I realize there's
other people where it does benefit it
like it actually helps them to work in
an office
but I just want to say like you know
you're right we don't know and people
need to stop being so confident about
you know blaming someone for failures at
the top yeah there was this clip of
Malcolm Gladwell basically saying
working from home is like ruining
everybody's life or whatever it's like I
don't know about that I'm not that that
seems like a bit much and I know he's
being controversial
um and trying to be titillating but yeah
I just I think we need a lot more
information and we not everybody will
agree on what it means to successfully
work from home and unless you first say
what are we measuring it's gonna be very
hard to get definitive answers
yeah you're exactly right uh so yeah
that's it for my call and I really
appreciate it all right George from
Virginia really appreciate hearing from
you